hé ouais c'est super sympa de te rencontrer
absolument
hé puis-je avoir deux bières merci mec excusez-
moi désolé celle-ci est à moi
oh désolé ma faute je n'ai jamais fait ça
avant
et cela m'a pris deux minutes de pratique
et j'ai maintenant cinq noyaux dans le
au fond de ce verre
[Musique]
je ne l'ai su que quelques jours plus tard et
cela m'a vraiment affecté je me
suis senti vraiment coupable parce que j'avais
reconnu le risque donc j'ai porté ça
avec moi pendant longtemps
et ça a été un tournant pour moi qui
c'est là que
j'ai décidé que j'allais être plus
vigilant que j'allais
parler si quelque chose me semblait étrange et je suis
définitivement beaucoup plus prudent c'était
le moment
pour moi et ce n'était même pas vous connaissez ma
propre expérience de première main  c'était
là où j'avais le potentiel j'avais l'
opportunité d'être un allié
et je n'étais pas
[Music]
donc
malheureusement ce n'est pas une
histoire exceptionnelle j'ai
d'innombrables et innombrables histoires comme ça
dans mes commentaires les gens ont vraiment saisi
cette opportunité
pour tendre la main et partager ce qui
leur est arrivé et
à d'autres personnes avec qui ils ont été ou
des gens qu'ils aiment et il
y a eu beaucoup de bonnes
conversations généralement les commentaires sont des
endroits effrayants mais
c'était vraiment agréable de voir des gens
partager leurs histoires et  s'éduquer
et se soutenir mutuellement donc
c'est merveilleux
[Musique]
j'ai reçu un certain nombre de commentaires où
les gens sont soit authentiques
soit font une blague vraiment insensible et
c'est à peu près la même chose c'est que c'est
une sorte
de tutoriel ou comment faire  ou cela va
encourager
les gens ou donner aux gens des informations sur la
façon de piquer un verre euh
à ceux qui sont vraiment
inquiets je comprends d'où
vient cette inquiétude
mais j'ai l'impression que la récompense l'emporte sur le
risque
dans ce cas je pense que si nous prenons  un
pas en arrière et regardez la situation dans son ensemble
que le nombre de personnes après avoir vu
cette vidéo qui vont être plus
vigilants à l'avenir
qui vont se construire de meilleures habitudes
afin de rester plus en sécurité
qui l'emporte sur le potentiel d'un petit
groupe de  les gens que
vous connaissez
s'inspirent involontairement de cette vidéo
je ne montre pas aux gens comment piquer la
boisson j'illustre simplement à quel point
cela peut être fait facilement votre blague sur le viol n'est pas
drôle
votre blague sur le viol n'est pas appréciée votre
blague sur le viol n'est pas  Je ne suis pas le bienvenu ici,
c'est essentiellement mon message que
vous